hang on a second there gang before we
get the show started the keep it moving
2021 tour
is in full swing as you know yeah we
have some additions
sure we have some announcements kippy
straighten them out
guys we're coming to providence rhode
island august 11th
uh we're going to be in boston
massachusetts august 12th shaolin new
brunswick new jersey
august 25th jersey stress factory we're
going to be
in timonium maryland outside baltimore
at magooby
uh-oh on august 26th then the big thing
moon tower comedy [ __ ] out we're gonna
be there
at the fest at the fest couple of festy
boys
uh that's gonna be at the end of
september on september 23rd 24th 25th
also another big announcement we're
going to be at skankfest
in houston uh that's going to be nov
november 5th 6th 7th plus we're going to
be adding more dates
it's going to be boncos get some tickies
it's going to be a good time can't wait
to see you there
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey everybody out there
and welcome back to everybody's favorite
new podcast this is
are you garbage it's a little show we
sit down with your favorite comedians we
find out they go
to be classy or if they're just a big
old piece of trash
i'm your host stage foley coming at you
on a beautiful day
we're down here at antootie's basement i
don't even want to get into it with you
okay
about what she's up to yeah so we'll
save it for off the air but we have to
have a little discussion
i can't wait my co-host is coming at you
from right next to me he is the
brains behind the operation he's really
an international business man he's kind
of the head bozo around here
so do me a favor make me look good show
him a little respect give it up for
kevin james
ryan everybody hey hey hey gang thanks
for tuning in as always please make sure
you rate view subscribe on itunes
full video available on youtube and as
you know those numbers are true the roof
through the roof they're [ __ ] cooking
and then patreon.com
is i mean that's where the real [ __ ]
magic's happening that's cooking with
gas over there oh yeah it's making a
couple of shekels
in our pocket so check that out you get
bonus episodes bonus content live
streams
the whole [ __ ] nine yards a bunch of
videos check it out very nice and having
a nice shout out to our producer
extraordinaire he's the magic man he
makes this all look good
give it up for t-bone mcmuffin toby
mcmullen what's up dudes what's up
t-bone nothing me and hank been
carpooling
this dude is a psycho
only guy i know who stops at green
lights for our protection okay
friday night when you're leaving the
city after doing spots these maniacs are
[ __ ] driving around out there so i
make sure no one's gonna come through
and [ __ ]
to crush us not going out now things are
good i'm in the passenger seat with a
pillow in my lap so i'll smash my head
on the dash
yeah it's a tough ride gang we could not
be more excited to have our incredibly
and i mean incredibly
special guest here with us today for the
first time
she's one of the stars over there at bar
stool sports pretty big dales
everybody loves her we love her she is
the co-host of because we got high and
of course
chicks in the office but the big
question about his mind today
is she garbage now we know there's a
long island pedigree in there
i can tell by the gold chains man i
don't i don't have mine
you came in like it came in like funk
master flex guys
it's like a carmelo soprano over here
gang i don't know my
number's in front of me but all signs
point to trash
telling you right there give me a nice
big round of applause
for maria chivo yeah you got
it what's up guys thank you for having
me i mean you guys are a great host by
the way
what a [ __ ] intro i really hope to be
here yeah the whole time i don't know if
you saw me but right before i said tebow
and i was mouthing that i don't know why
this one
got me so nervous yeah the last name
last name the last name because you
don't usually rock that you're like
madonna at this point
yeah which is pretty cool oh
i mean it's just not a good last name
triple is a tough one
it's it's just not there's nothing to it
but sorry pulling that single name
is pretty that's a pretty cool that's
like a pop star i wish i could just get
the instagram to just be rhea but it's
like my
full name it's very confusing who has is
there aria
i think there is yeah there's gotta be
there's gotta be an artist you're just
some bozo
no i think some sort of artist yeah
something so you could get a three
character instagram hand now that's like
powerful just
three just r-i-a that would really
elevate me like i think that maria
chiffo's was stopping me but
it's a pop icon all right she's younger
yeah look at the chains give us the
the full backstory and as we said before
we talked a little bit at friday night
pints but we're really gonna get into it
um give us the whole deal long island
the whole nine
yes long island born and raised you want
to know where i was born alone 100
winthrop hospital oh she gave us a high
i got
because i fancy because i'll so i just
wanted to give the hospital name
who the [ __ ] knows what hospital i i
don't know i just wanted to throw that
out there just in case because you know
people know like
they know that the hospital justin
bieber was born at so maybe if i have a
super fan out there
i'll be like oh ria was born at winthrop
hospital wow give that to them
that's pretty good um lived on long
island my whole life where in long
island what's up
nassau county nassau because there's two
counties right or there's
the suffolk and nassau what's the trash
you want
see i would say suffolk but then
somebody from suffolk would say nasa
which one's the hamptons in
i think suffolk yeah yeah so nassau's
attraction
i didn't want to answer that one i also
am not good at geography so you're
asking me questions
which would like geography jesus christ
it's an island
it's the county you grew up in well i
yeah born and raised there went to
catholic school my whole life so is that
is that nice or it depends it can go
either way
but it is technically a private school
all girls catholic schools no
boys and girls boys and girls okay all
right parents together
i have an older brother and older sister
and
it's really just as like italian as it
gets yeah there's nothing
else to the mix besides just straight
just long island
long island italian see here's the thing
though
i wouldn't describe my family as guidos
but if you met them
sure of course you would probably
describe them as guidos you're dripping
in gold
i got my first car last week which is a
mercedes
what i sent everyone a picture of it and
they were like you're just in the mop
like you're a mob is it pink no it's
black it's all black
outside black and the inside yeah you
just picked up a benz i just picked up a
bag he does all right
yeah is there any is there anyone in
your family named anthony that you refer
to as anthony
yeah is there any ants on my family
there's there's a ton of anthony's but
i'll tell you this this will shock you
we do not call them tony really and it
stayed as anthony stays as anthony
yeah respectable a lot of michaels
franks
of course anthony's and then it kind of
you know
yeah do you do that crazy maria's very
old school yeah
maria yeah my mom's name is rosaria so
holy [ __ ] get the meatballs go oh wait
and her dad
her dad's name is aquino holy [ __ ]
yeah god damn yeah that's like real
guinea [ __ ]
that's real new york
[Laughter]
that guy knows how to grow san marzano
peppers
holy [ __ ] your mom and dad aren't from
italy though right no they're not but
are they born and raised long island
well my my mom it's like a billy joel
something yeah oh yeah
my dad born and raised long island elmo
my mom
lived in queens or brooklyn okay and
then
valley stream which is just if you're
from long island these are very italian
areas like you know what we're talking
about the stream's marinara sauce just
so everybody knows
yeah it's a good red salt get it right
from the stream
uh what did your parents do growing up
my dad
was in the union insulation shout out to
the insulators
[Laughter]
shout out to local 12. i like it
she doesn't know the neighborhood she
grew up in which he knows the local
number that's who pays the [ __ ] bills
you know the local number my dad's gonna
be like why are you giving out like our
social security
on the podcast now i gotta whack these
two
i kind of like the fat one but i gotta
do what i gotta do my mom was a orthotec
nice yeah okay
blue collar love it and you didn't go to
you
didn't go to college right so i went to
college
kind of not really like i did a semester
kind of not real i did a semester at
pace university in the city
her film dropped out of there then i was
a pharmacy tech
okay and then i went to fit okay and
then i started working at barcelona fit
at the same time and then i dropped out
fit yeah of course
it's a smart move at that point yes
there was no reason for me to stay there
any longer
right what did you want what do you want
to do at fit
well was that just so now i'm going to
dive i'm really going to dive into my
life now
yeah let's go i was a like a child model
actress starting from when i was eight
years old okay so
in and out of the city four times a week
my dad would drive me he he'd literally
drive into the city at 4 a.m
then he would get home at around he's
like [ __ ] in and out he'd get home
like
any time between 10 and 12 every day get
home
pick me out of school drive me to the
city for auditions acting class whatever
it is i did that from
when i was eight years old up until like
the middle of high school
you were in and out of class like they
would the people in
school first of all my parents were like
don't tell anybody like kids are like
really mean they're going to be really
mean to you if they know
so for a really long time i didn't tell
any of my friends you were like
they thought i was so sick even the
teachers thought i was really sick
and one day they were like they talked
to my parents like what what's going on
with her
and that's when the doors open my
parents put in i remember this
you know like one of those uh envelopes
the yellow yellow folders yeah the
manila folder they like put in
all like like uh catalogs that i did and
like my comp cards my headshots and they
were like
just bring this in and give it to one of
your teachers and slide it across again
i remember going into into class one day
and was like my dad told me to give this
to you and then
from that point on the teachers knew and
then none of the kids knew
and then one of uh a kid at school
parents saw me on the side of a bus i
actually have the picture on my phone
saw me on the side of a bus called my
house and they were like uh do you guys
know that they're using maria's picture
on the side of a bus
and then my yeah my parents were like we
just have to tell everyone they thought
i was like hannah montana at the time it
was a huge deal
that's awesome what kind of brands were
you was it like print work yeah like
kohl's target
sears like all that stuff and then i i
auditioned for like
a ton of tv shows and movies like just
endless
yeah from what you're telling me
seeing your dad is like a stage dad my
dad is literally chris jenner i'm not
joking that's really crazy
ultimate stage dad ultimate stage dad
you don't really i don't think the guys
at the local know about this
oh yeah about his beautiful baby angel
that maria
she's a beautiful child she belongs in
movies at maria
she's gonna be a star i'm telling you
right now she's gonna be a star
i picture them all sitting at the shop
like pulling for they're all about the
kohl's catalog
my whole life all i heard growing up was
that like i was going to be
the breadwinner of the family they were
like she's our way out yeah
still to this way out of where just a
long island
or something like nassau county it's not
that bad no it's really not
serious i actually had a great life it's
so funny she's a way out
that is a billy joel song you know
anthony down at the union's got a good
looking daughter
did you ever hit like uh did you ever
hit like a huge payday well so
actually this is kind of a crazy story i
did like a lot of print work which is
true it's cool whatever but
you were working yeah i want no i was
working more as like a model
but i like as a child model and i
actually
side note one of the sickest things was
as a child model
sometimes you do just like fit modeling
where they don't even take pictures of
you
you go in and you try on like 50 pairs
of jeans it takes like i don't know
half an hour to an hour like thousands
of dollars
awesome that's it like just i showed up
one day for 15 minutes and just
like a thousand dollars damn damn so it
was crazy but
i could get it obviously wanted to be an
actor way more right
tons of auditions and movies you're
always being told like you get so close
and then they're like oh this is the
reason why you didn't get this this is
oh
literally your name's too italian like
that's those are things i would get
lose the gold
they always used to tell my manager they
were like her face looks so
old but her body looks so young like
just like
it was very it was crazy and i went into
an audition one day
walked down and i was like i said to my
parents i was like i nailed that if i
don't get this
i am done i am not doing this anymore
kid you not the next day my manager
calls and they're like she got the part
i told you guys i nailed this
because i went to a private catholic
school the way that this system works
was
so [ __ ] up we have these things called
comps and they work as like
at the end of the year they count as 50
of your grade and you take it for every
subject and it's like six days in a row
of tests
okay you can literally get 90s all year
you fail that test it drops it all the
way it's 50 percent of your grade
the filming started in the middle of
when these tests were
my dad called up the school and he
explained the situation was like listen
like she's she got a part like she's got
to film
she got a movie yeah is there any way
around this
and they were like well she's gonna have
to go to summer school if she doesn't do
the test and my dad was like well uh she
can't go to summer school like i said
my daughter will get a big role yeah
they were like well she's gonna have to
go to public school
and that's when i was like dad no i
can't go to public school it was
i was ninth grade i just made all my
friends sure of course i
really was focused on after years of
doing this i was just i just wanted to
[ __ ] hang out my friends party
so i gave it up and i i didn't do it it
was almost away from the role
the contest cartoon network you could
look it up and i didn't do it but
i think cartoon network yeah it was a
cartoon network movie i was hoping for
like avatar
no it wasn't okay it wasn't that cool
but it was pretty cool you walked away
from star wars or something like that
it was some seth green side project i
mean this piece of shit's got a 5.5 on
imdb i don't think he missed out that
man
i think i'm doing okay now yeah but at
the time you give that up and you're
like oh [ __ ]
i just like threw it all away but that's
crazy yeah
that's a different kind of life man as a
kid as a kid
i have lived a wildlife for 23 years did
you want to did you
crazy did you want to do that when you
were a kid yeah so you're the one that
wanted to be in it yeah
i've like begged my parents i was like
this is what i want to do and then my
dad did a lot of research because
there's a lot of scammers out there you
know you sign up they make you pay
one thing we learn is you never pay for
anything of course you never only get
paid
that's my dad we don't pay for anything
i ain't paying
some of the greatest agencies i went on
some of the coolest auditions it was
awesome that's so sick yeah was it was i
think it was the coolest audition my
first audition ever
i wouldn't say it's the coolest but my
first audition ever was to play young
angelina jolie in salt
and when we saw it oh there was only
eight girls who auditioned and to be
honest i don't look like her
as a kid like i wouldn't say i looked
like her but maybe like
you can whatever the girl who got the
part looked absolutely nothing like that
it was crazy but with the makeup and
stuff it's
it's whatever but that was my first
audition ever that's not because i
couldn't imagine i mean we're
you know we're trying to manage comedy
and show business as adults and it's
[ __ ] i couldn't imagine like not getting
auditions as a kid i'd be [ __ ] losing
my mind
i thought growing up i was like oh i
have no issues from this because you
know
the child actors talk all the time like
about the rejection is so hard and i was
like i grew up
fine oh it it hit me for sure the
insecurities
really hit me definitely that's it's
crazy to be able to try to navigate that
as a kid
we slept to make sure that foley gets
his juice box gets real
i need my cheese stick probably at noon
how much of a north hot so this was 90
percent of your childhood
yes but this ended in freshman year high
school
yeah but a majority of my it was normal
because i wasn't [ __ ] booking
anything
so i was just going on all these
auditions but i was still
going home i'll be back for the second
half of soccer practice i like how hard
you are on yourself
like i wasn't booking nothing i was
[ __ ] blowing it so it didn't matter
anyway
i mean you just get so close you know
yeah
i'm with you i love it yeah first child
star we've had in here first child
star i wouldn't even put star on it
whatever that's what we're using
inspiring child star
she was almost in uh uh so what's it
called salt she was almost
i i i'm trying to think of some of the
movies that i auditioned for remember
the movie
vacation they did the new one sure
yes that one with the the little the kid
meets a girl
who were you reading for the girl that
the little kid really
yeah and then i actually played jason
today because his daughter for mother's
day
it's like big child no they were all the
time
my my manager and agents did not let me
audition for
anything less than like a prominent
speaking role because she said that if
you do
extra work you can never be in that show
yeah again
again so i wasn't allowed to do anything
but
audition for like those types of roles
oh man
i could see your mom and dad back in the
day my mom my mom not at all
my mom was not involved really at all
like she would
my parents are like this like they'd do
everything together so my mom would
come but she
is not a stage parent at all like once
your dad was the insulator
don't forget jazz hands either my dad
would
tell me this is [ __ ] up my dad would
tell me to cry before auditions because
i have hazel eyes and they will look
greener when i cry
oh this guy's bonkos this is psycho
jesus
christ they look greener i never heard
that
did he ever try to put the screws in at
casting directors like if you want this
duck work done in this building ever
again
i'm checking these pipes it ain't up to
code i have a couple people come down
here start asking some questions
get a girl in a part will you give it a
pawn she's gotta hazel eyes give it you
get me angelina jolie on the phone right
now
i'll talk to her okay that's
what a wild dynamic that is cuckoo gang
let's talk about movement
pretty cool stuff yep couple of college
dropouts got together they created this
insane watch company
yeah all right with fantastic designs
good pricing the best then they moved on
the sunglasses
now they're killing it they're doing
everything 160 countries
you can get movement products shipped to
and right now
they got a 28 off sale going
for their eight year anniversary every
single thing
on their website 28 off sunglasses
jewelry watches you name it they got it
and they are fantastic yeah they sent us
a pair of shades foley got a new watch i
got a pretty cool watch
coming in if it's a blue one foley's a
watch guy i'm now a new shade guy
everybody knows that
so we each got it's perfect you look
cool you feel cool it's good
quality material everything's easy peasy
you look a little different it's a
little different than what everybody
else has
sharp it's nice they know what they're
doing it's quality uh
modern watches for a fair price super
durable sunglasses with uv rated
polarized lens and timeless styles baby
you're not walking around looking like a
bozo you're coming correct when you're
using movement it's the perfect gift for
friends family whoever
a loved one uh feel cool we're in the
movement family i know
uh like foley said movement is going out
going all out for their eighth birthday
it's their their eighth birthday it's
the biggest sale of the year take
advantage
of these price points before they go
celebrate
eight years of movement with 28 off
statewide
don't miss the biggest sell of the year
go to mvmt.com
garbage to enjoy the 28 off one more
time
28 off statewide mvmt.com
garbage and join the move support for
this podcast
is brought to you by our good friends at
manscaped
we got em and we love them the best in
the biz you gotta keep it clean
downstairs
and they've really perfected the
instrument
to do that because you could go out and
just get a regular trimmer but you don't
know what's going on
no manscaped quiet powerful motor in it
get it wet you can use it in the shower
has a light so you can see where you're
going
we're talking a top shelf yeah product
here
yeah guys this thing's cooking i you
know i gotta admit i used to be a bozo i
used to shave with blade and creams
putting your life in your hands down
there you might not be able to have kids
again i'll be one of the founding
fathers
that's how george washington died but
now with the manscape blonde
lawnmower 4.0 one more time baby that's
the lawnmower 4.0 the
fourth generation trimmer they're just
making it better and better just when
you think you can't get any better they
got the guys in the lab with the pen and
the pad
making it better baby uh i mean the
craftsmanship
uh we were one of the first people to
try it and i gotta tell you i mean i'm
clean as a whistle down there fantastic
especially in the summer it helps with
the heat helps with the chafing
the whole nine yards um they've
engineered the ultimate groin and body
trimmer by focusing on intelligent
functionality and incredible comfort for
the grooming experience
uh the upgraded trimmer includes a
multi-function on and off switch that
can engage
a travel lock it gives you the ability
to turn
the 4000k led spotlight on and off when
you need
more precise shave really bam bam
things out you're not flying blind down
there you know what i mean you got to
get you got to get eyes on this subject
who's got eyes on the little guy you
know what i mean
like a bunny in the weeds yeah the
lawnmower 4.0 even allows you to
customize your trim through additional
guard lengths with widths
with sizes one through four so maybe you
want you know
a little bit longer maybe a little
shorter maybe you know you get to choose
you get the style whatever you want to
do
do you um and if you're using the same
trimmer for your face you are for your
ball bag you're messing with bros
yeah what are we doing that's how you
get that's how you get a ring worm or
something yeah
uh plus this thing you can't even hear
when it's on it's humming you could do
it in a bedroom
girl sleep right through it nice uh so
guys get 20
off and free shipping with promo code
garbage at manscape.com
that's 20 off with free shipping at
manscaped.com use promo code garbage
unlock your confidence
and you will always use the right tools
for the job with manscaped stamps.com
gang
stamps.com i'll say it again one more
time i'm not afraid to
no stamps.com get on it
use it we love it you're going to love
it
bingo yeah because i tell you what it's
a summer you don't want to be wasting
time in the post office
no because last year you were stuck
inside now you don't want to have your
freedom and then you got to go to the
post office and do this do that just use
stamps.com man i know we got a lot of
small business owners out there
we use it it's unbelievable it saves you
time you get good rates from usps
and ups and they send you everything
that you need
to get started yeah guys they sent us a
package we mailed out all the cards and
you know the merch that way it's easy
peasy they send it to you all you need
is a computer
the printer the roll the stickers bada
bing bada boom you slap print it out you
slap it on all you need is internet and
a computer
you can do this in a home office car
whatever rv camper
trailer park wherever you are you can do
this we printed the labels
packaged them all up knocked them all
out we had them in a bunch of bags we
walked right down to the post office
dumped them right in there we were in
and out in two seconds want to hear
something even better
tell me kippy you can do it you can you
can schedule a pickup so they come and
do all the heavy lifting for you
i like it we just did it because it's
right next door so it's easy i need my
cardio plus the big man's gotta get his
cardio guys stamps.com is a no-brainer
saving nearly one million small business
owners like you time and money
you can save up to 40 off of usps 66
off ups shipping rates what are we doing
here and with the save and switch
feature you can quickly compare carriers
to find the best rates at the best
time uh stop wasting time by going to
the post post office go to stamps.com
and said
uh there's no risk with our promo code
garbage you'll get a special a special
offer that includes a four-week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale no
long-term commitments
tell them to kick rocks if you don't
like it but you're gonna love it that's
right
uh stamps.com click the microphone at
the top of the homepage type in garbage
at stamps.com promo code garbage
stamps.com never go to the post office
again now back
to the show that's [ __ ] crazy all
right let me get into some
some questions here i believe we shall
okay are you garbage
so the long island nassau county
uh shaw county not suffic uh what was
the name of the supermarket
your family went to growing up and or
now
wall bounds but then it's changed to
stop and shop wall bounce that sounds
fancy
i don't know anything with a name is
pretty good i feel wall bounds
what do you mean anything with a name
isn't any groceries no i mean like
that's somebody's name
like that all the realms yeah well
there's not a job
yeah there's nothing there's for sure a
steve wall bound
yeah that's a land there's a wall bounds
family that's collecting checks every
week stop and shop that's that's middle
of the road though that's good yeah
okay do your parents still live in the
same house you grew up in yes all right
so we can't ask for the name of the
street we'd like to ask for the name of
the street that you grew up on because
that can determine a drive
you know a drive a circle was it a cold
what was it
no we see we did talk about this i
didn't know what a cul-de-sac was when
you guys came in
it's not a cul-de-sac i can tell you
that much
not knowing what a cul-de-sac is any
summer camps
i didn't do summer camps okay all right
you ever go for the plus model on an
iphone
get the big one now i do you do yeah
that's
trash i'm a plus guy oh oh plus
no no pro sorry pro oh okay sorry not
plus
all right i like it did you have a sweet
16
no i didn't have a sweet 16 but we went
to punta cana for my
for my sweet 16. who did my family and i
punta cana what the [ __ ] it was an
all-inclusive person
it's like hedonism or something like
that wow took you to sandals
listen you can have a party with your
friends and we can go get drunk in the
dominican
what do you want to do that's exactly
what it was they sold it to me they were
like
we're going to spend all this money on
one night or one week
and i was like that is trash logic and i
love it that's what i have too
yeah i mean i was like no brainer
decision for me yeah
they just wanted to go down there and
get weird for a couple of days you guys
are sitting in the hotel with pizzas
were you sneaking booze at 16 when you
were down there
not sneaking like i was allowed to drink
i'm the i'm the youngest
child so when it got to me all rules
really went
out the window like i was really allowed
to do whatever i wanted i could drink
i could smoke i could have cigs not six
but i
if i asked i actually remember one time
i asked my mom i was like can i try it
she was like yeah
go ahead man she smoked oh yeah my mom
still smokes to this day my mom
what's her what's her brand um seneca
seneca this is the green the yeah
she's not good those are prison
cigarettes
here's the thing though i will say this
if i showed you a picture of my mom
i don't think because you know when you
think of a woman who's been smoking for
as many years
sure where's all you're really picturing
my mom is
beautiful like you would see a picture
of my mom and not think like that woman
has been smoking for as long as she has
and i remember as a kid i was in fourth
grade and my parents went to go get
hypnotized
to not smoke anymore yeah my parents did
that too they went to go get
hypnotized
very big the other time you should be
getting hypnotized is in front of a
studio audience and you think you're a
chicken for a couple
of minutes no no no hypnotized not smoke
anymore it worked for my dad
my dad caught my mom he was picking her
up from work one day and
he caught her in the back of her job
smoking a cigarette and it was like the
biggest
fight ever because my dad was like if i
knew you were smoking this whole time i
would have been smoking this whole time
i've been missing out on all these
things
and then they both started smoking again
and then just a spidey cheese yeah
that's love i love that and my mom has
not quit to this day my dad
he doesn't smoke cigarettes but he has
literally three jewels charging at at
once
i remember that you said yeah jewels the
jewel is hanging from his mouth
he talks and he says something like dad
i can't hear you and my mom's like we
can't hear you with that stupid thing in
your mouth and he's like
what it doesn't affect anything and he's
just he can't stop with it
man i actually
hated the fact that they smoked
cigarettes growing up because
my stuff would always smell like
cigarettes like i went to when i was
in high school my music class for a girl
it's tough and i remember my music
teacher one day we weren't allowed to
leave the school for
lunch or anything like that some people
could do that we weren't allowed to do
that
you can't even who wasn't allowed to do
that my entire school yeah
i think that's yeah that only thing that
only really happens in like i don't know
tv shows disney shows but we weren't
allowed to like step outside
so my teacher one day like confronted
the whole class and was like
somebody is going outside
before this class and smoking cigarettes
and he walked over to my area and i was
so embarrassed you know it was you at
that time
i knew in my head i was like it's
absolutely me because
i am going to dude my mom rips burnies i
literally would
scream my head off at my mom every day
like my stuff smells like cigarettes i
smell like cigarettes so i knew it was
me and it was so embarrassing
now i'm glad they did because i'm not
the person out that gets mad when other
people are smoking cigarettes because
now you you'll hang out with people and
somebody will like get a pack of
cigarettes or somebody will be smoking
and then you'll see a few people be like
yeah like you're [ __ ] a cigarette
okay i'm not anybody we hang out with
you
we hang out with dirtbags yeah i don't
want to be that person so
that now i'm like all right whatever oh
yeah that's good though that that's good
to have
you know you you have a you know uh what
is it like
antibodies built up against it you can
just hang with it and empathy for yeah
exactly smelling like six as a kid is
tough real time that's tough
because i used to i'd put my clothes in
my wrestling bag and then go to school
and then by the time i pulled them out
it was like somebody like my mom had
smoked in my bag
and walking around school with that it's
terrible that's tough
yep trash okay that is a garbage
were you a coke or pepsi family growing
up coke okay
it's the right answer with dinner uh yes
religious i
used to drink so much soda to the point
i went to the hospital in high school i
had a kidney infection from the amount
of soda i drank
what they told me that i couldn't drink
soda anymore and then i had
headaches like every day after that i
just like oh my head hurts all the time
my mom
my mom was like i have a little bit of
soda i bet it fixes it drink the soda
immediately felt better
better i was literally having withdrawal
headaches from not having soda
god damn because they kept stacks and
stacks of soda in my house
orange soda coke i love it
also how what an old school mom taking
it for this
take a shot of coke zero like when i
would wake up in the middle of the night
and you're really
thirsty and you get water i would crack
open a coke
a screamer out of the fridge oh man
there's a bite to that
there's nothing there's the bubbles i
like to burn yeah i love that there's no
better feeling than like a nice cold
soda going down your throat
it's unbelievable yeah they really i
don't know if the guy that invented coke
knew what he was doing
but man that's a [ __ ] winner right
there like
there was literally coke in it yeah it
was coconut so it makes sense
yeah yeah we missed out what are you
going to do
have to add our own huh what do you got
big man
what do i got uh favorite salad dressing
it's ranch no it's not caesar balsamic
vinegar
that's a [ __ ] damn dad i was not
expecting really it was a crummy italian
something no balsamic
balsamic vinegar thousand island kid to
me i don't know that's as classy as it
gets
really i think thanks sonic yes i love
balsamic yeah
bam okay uh and was the bend your first
car or what was your first car
well the benz was my person your
personal heart yeah but can we take a
second here real quick
just bought a [ __ ] benz when we sing
it i'm releasing it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter yeah that's the smart
way to go it was a big moment you know
my mom
like started hysterical crying in the
mercedes-benz place
and she said i just never thought
someone in our family would be able to
get a bed
and i was like shut up right now i think
i want to return it
i'm going to cry that's so we were in
part
like that's the thing though we weren't
poor the first car remember though they
had a pathfinder
so a nissan pathfinder and then we had a
rav4
bad yep tough luck
and there's a kanye line it's like what
do you think i wrapped forward or
push your [ __ ] rav4 yeah and as a kid
i was like god damn
yeah you're driving on the raft who
drove that your mom or your dad
my mom my dad had a uh nissan sentra for
a while
okay like a little car because he just
would drive it into the city so you just
want a little thing and that's something
yeah and now they have a nissan murano
which is still kind of like they just
live in the nissan family i have no idea
so that's why my mom was crying about
him
no no they're like it was crazy i was
like you have to stop crying it's making
me uncomfortable that's fantastic did
you let your mom rip bernies
in the benz absolutely not yeah no no no
smoking in the car
so they used to smoke in the car all the
time and then this new one that they got
my dad was like
you really cannot and we actually talked
about it when we went to go pick up my
car
my dad was like no smoking in the car
ria like no no weed no cigarettes don't
smoke in the car you don't want to do
that to your car and my mom was like
yeah he doesn't let me smoke in our car
i was like rightfully so
yeah yeah yeah yeah especially if it's a
lease did they go with you to get the
car like did your dad go in and work the
guy over a little bit
actually my sister came with me really
yes ma'am look because my dad wasn't too
thrilled about this like he was just
like why must you guys
yeah a perfectly good rav4 sitting in
the driveway
literally he was like he's like why why
such a luxury car i was like
well i can afford that i don't really
buy a lot of other things i don't treat
myself really ever so like i just want
to get this
and he's like fine whatever go ahead is
that your sister what's the first big
problem is that your friend because
we always ask people successful people
what was your first big
word yeah for sure okay i love that yeah
i love it yourself congratulations
thank you that's [ __ ] fantastic i
just got a kia no big deal
[Laughter]
what are you saying pretty sick
sweet i got a jeep latitude parked
outside that's in your parents name
my parents name do you get an easy pass
uh
i take my parents oh keep in the trash
yeah yeah i use my parents easy pass too
sending that right to the home office
she's 23. you're 45.
there's a difference i gotta get what
are your huh what do you mean your
your car is in your parents team my car
isn't my parent's name so be weird if
the easy pass wasn't in because i'm a
loser
i gotta put this together you gotta
build that credit
credit's actually up oh there's an
interesting thing here we go you have
credit cards
i only have one credit card and what's
the limit on it not
high and it's it's higher than ours so
you trust me a thousand
really because i never i literally never
use it i only use my debit card so
it does not move mine was at 500 up
until about three days ago when they
just juiced me
also around we're around the same mine's
currently same thing 200.
i just got denied i got then i tried to
open 200
yeah you're talking
and i got denied this morning trying to
open one
in the company's name that is unreal
that's not good
yeah we're [ __ ] dirt balls that's
patreon.com patreon
those numbers are cooking though we're a
cash business i don't know if you've
been over to patreon
just wait one year you guys that limit's
gonna yeah just got increased
like two days ago i already maxed it out
though that burger got a thousand a
month a lot different than 500 i'll tell
you that
jesus christ um hmm
just one card capital one what do you
got no it's a jetblue card
because i like well here's the thing i
actually used to like flying jetblue
i've really switched to delta in my
opinion really jetblue
was good they really started cutting
some corners and making some
they've made some changes yeah and delta
is really winning people over with their
tv selection i'm not gonna lie and
by winning people are all right i'm
saying me yeah that's great he's all
right i like when there's no one next to
you
then you could put the the flight
tracker on feel like you're in a little
command
yes oh man we flew to hawaii last time
me and my girlfriend had a whole row i
had like five tvs going i was ordering
snacks for people that weren't there
yeah he's in the bathroom he wants
cookies how are you going to hawaii but
your credit card limit is 500
cash business yeah we're a cash business
i was never
i was i never really had any credit
either i didn't have a bank account up
until
[Music]
two not too long ago yeah to keep up
appearances you guys are making me feel
good
yeah you should feel good you're doing
great also she's 23.
so i mean that's good that's that's what
i'm saying she's making us look like
[ __ ]
yeah you buy it if we were 23 we would
still look like this one
this girl's got a benz i got a kia yeah
we stink if he didn't say that on the
door when you walk down
all right i don't think my credit will
ever be whatever side note but continue
that's either here nor there have you
ever flown private no
you haven't been on the what i know it's
honestly kind of disgraceful that
[ __ ] all these people at the company
get on private jets and i haven't been
on one
what is the criteria over there you got
to be doing something for barstool right
i i think it's whenever you're doing
something with dave because
yeah because if you're doing something
for barcelo that has nothing to do with
dave they're just going to book you a
regular
flight yeah like they're not going to
put you on a private jet it's when it
has to do with
your coach right yeah yeah okay um
when it's with dave then i think that's
yeah he's not flying he's not flying no
it's okay
that guy rolls heavy and then when you
book your own tickets you book coach or
first class
i do not book first class but with delta
i do um delta comfort yeah
we got delta comfort tomorrow really you
do that's awesome no wait i lie we have
it on the way back from on the way back
it was
awesome you guys are gonna have a great
time delta comfort wait a minute delta
comfort
the seats are a little thicker right no
there's more space no don't get this
they now the the they got the
thing for your feet the recline for your
feet so you because you know how
annoying it is on the airplane that you
can recline your back
but with your feet your feet are just on
the floor yeah i mean they're like a
gorilla imagine sitting next to me it's
brutal i have it's not fun
and now you could put your feet up
that's pretty look at that
tv we're doing all right look at that i
got delta comfort money to get us
on the way back from cleveland it's
pretty good let me ask you this
um if you go out to eat as a family
do does your family stack the plates
when they're done with them to make it
easier for the server
no yes you think that's trashy it's not
classy
i just think it's like why yes to make
it easy for the server
i guess it is making it easier for the
server but
isn't it also their job yes and i'll
listen i'll agree
with the little signs of class over here
no i know that that's right
[Laughter]
you're not you're not you're not wrong
also i think it depends
on the caliber of place of the dining
establishment
if you're at a if you're at a middle of
the road decent place
they're johnny on they've got they've
got the busboy they got people coming by
this trip
like an applebee's they're just like
yeah at applebee's you're stacking
plates to make your other room because
you're waiting
you have all the apps you got to make
room for that what was the last place
you and your family went out to eat
together as a family do you remember
my god no i honestly don't even remember
um we used to go to chili's all the time
without growing up there we go
all right we're back i can't i i
can't remember the last time we all like
i feel like the last time we all went
out to eat together as a family we were
probably in florida or something
but why why the laughter florida
just a tragic place yeah you aren't in
the south of france
i love florida i really do west palm
beach
yeah it's nice is that where you got
where would you guys go go on vacation
going because you you had just said
before
we started recording that you had never
been to the jersey shore before
yeah we would go to florida a lot yeah
because we have family there
so we always went there my grandparents
lived there now we have
their house there so like my ice
when my grandma died the house then went
under like my mom and her sister's name
so now i tell everyone that i have a
house in florida but really like
my my nano still lives there yes no no
grandpa yeah yeah whatever
um but where we would go on vacation you
say
we have a house in florida yeah yeah i'm
like we have a house in florida yeah
that's trashy i love it yeah i do it too
yeah
because i was asking my parents how do i
go about this i'm like
you know it's under mom's name so
technically it is it's our
house and what do you mean like how do i
explain it to people
yeah like when i say that i have a house
in florida like do i say it's my nano's
house or to
say it's my house my dad goes just say
just say it's your house
nobody has to know yeah and now i'm
telling everyone like the full detailed
explanation of it doesn't matter i love
it
i like your dad just so you'll never
know if they ask the second question
keep the [ __ ] move who is she about
the house
the amount of questions that my so i
actually didn't live at home for the
past
i don't know four years maybe three
years like i
lived with a roommate and then i lived
with my boyfriend but we broke up
recently so it's already here no it's
okay good to hear that i don't know what
way it goes
either way either way i'm now living at
home again
so i'm really getting like the movie
everything's coming but i'm loving it
because i have a newfound appreciation
to just laugh at them
yes i've been removed whereas everybody
else has not been like my sister
and my brother who are older than i am
my sister's married
still lives in the house with her
husband there as well my brother lives
there with his girlfriend as well and my
mom and dad live there and my nano's
there right now so it's all of them in
the house
yeah we gotta we gotta unpack that a
little bit
the house that you grew up in the house
i grew up in your older brother and
older sister now live in that house they
still live there how many bedrooms is it
um there's not enough i'm guessing no no
no there there is
one two three there's four upstairs okay
okay
right one oh no there's a downstairs bed
four no and then the
so we had a really big basement that my
parents turned into an apartment half of
it so half the basement
has an apartment and uh
yeah who was the apartment built for my
cousin
of course yes that's never enough but
then they yeah wait why
they just i guess needed a place to live
were they gonna were they gonna rent
from
they they like actually paid payments
yeah okay yes
so and in our world that's what's known
as a tough look
yeah for for both parties for everybody
involved
all part all parties involved except for
you you can hop in the bench and get out
of there
she's got to get back in cousin does not
live there anymore obviously because my
sister and her husband now
are staying in there they just got
married last year okay so they live down
there
and then my brother still lives at home
and his girlfriend basically lives there
as well
and they're in his room and then i have
my room my nano staying in my sister's
old room that's upstairs and then
obviously my parents are in their room
now who's the oldest your sister my
sister's the oldest sister's the oldest
29.
she's 29 she just got married yes okay
and they
they moved in with you guys they didn't
move and they've never left
oh really like my sister and my brother
have never
left i have left twice
i'm back yeah because i lived in the
city when i went to college
in the city for that short amount of
time came back then
moved into the city for a while you are
the right winner in the family own i
am in a couple years you're going to own
that house and they're all going to be
living
i could easily live in the city now i
just i'm like well
i might as well just for the summer
being on long island i'm like
yeah and then i come home and i am
filled with entertainment i haven't i
used to watch so much tv i haven't
watched tv
like i used to because i just come home
and we sit around the table
and the [ __ ] that flies out of all of
their mouths
i wish i could record but i can't like
especially on long island yes it would
be dangerous but they are
out of their minds but now i used to get
very mad at it
and now i love it i think it's the
funniest thing yeah
when you leave them and then come back
and you're removed from that reality yes
it's like going back you're like oh
they're cartoon characters this is
yeah insane they have never seen
anything but long island like to them
like that's basically just how they act
like they are
so far removed from reality but it's
hilarious
i also your brother and sister sitting
there like why the [ __ ] would we ever
leave she leaves and keeps coming back
you know what i mean like yeah there's
nothing for us out there i'm being
honest with you if
it i would if i was i would move in with
my parents and stay there
forever like that's how much i like
hanging out with them and i i like that
vibe
i get it i mentioned the other day to my
uh family i was like i think like
or sometime in the fall i think is when
i'm gonna start looking for apartments
again my sister didn't talk to me the
rest of the day
why because they don't want you to leave
no literally didn't speak to me the rest
of the day
and then texted me like two paragraphs
being like
i really think it's a bad idea for you
to move back to the city like you really
should stay home and save money like
this that the other thing i'm like i
don't need to do that though yeah
i can i could move out and it will be
fine
she'd miss you that's what it is yeah
yeah they all want you it's fun when
everybody's in the house
you guys do a big sunday dinner so
my mom makes pasta meatballs every
sunday yes
yes she does knocks it out of the park
oh they're really good obviously i'm
like my mom makes the best meatballs
this actually past uh weekend obviously
was italy versus england yeah
final and we had like a major italian
day like my mom made
sausage and peppers pasta meatballs
pasta salad
we had all the desserts the rainbow
cookies all the family members were over
that's all right yeah yeah damn all
right you have to invite the cousins
they were already there yeah they were
downstairs
uh they literally lived down the block
so yeah um
this is one that we've done uh i haven't
done a while do you have any answer
uncles
who don't use their real name such as
like an uncle
you know or yeah or an aunt or an aunt
toddy
no no okay ah
what about nicknames in the house uncle
ray-ray or cookie
oh yeah co what ankle and cookie yeah
you got it in cookie yeah that would
count yeah but
here's the thing i don't think that's a
government name i have an aunt cookie
but like
we're not so close that i don't even
want to dive into okay fair enough yeah
yeah not like that but i'm just like if
cookie finds out i was talking about on
this podcast i'm gonna call my dad and
be like why the [ __ ]
is my name being brought up i hear she's
in a city running her mouth again
it's me cookie call me back literally
i heard she's moving out leaving a
family has anyone in your family ever
said you think you're better than me
oh
because my aunt debbie lives down the
block from us and holy [ __ ]
you do not want to be on her bad side
she
threatened my life a couple months ago
about months ago a couple couple months
ago
can i tell you i don't even remember
what i did
i don't know what i did i may have like
maybe
became successful that's what you do
maybe i didn't respond like an
invitation to something where i didn't
go to something or whatever
she literally said to my dad does she
know who i am
my debbie my my dad told me this
and i was like what do i have to fear
for my life right now from
aunt debbie's telling me do you know who
i am yikes i'm a little
wait finds out you gotta bend she ain't
gonna be happy about that
she came over to see the bench she was
happy about the bends
she's happy about the benz all right you
got to stay on aunt tubby's good side
though cause
yeah pick your ass whose sister is it
my dad's your dad my dad has four
sisters three sisters
had she a lot older than you like aunt
age
yeah i wouldn't say too much older in
her 50s okay
all right yeah she's in her 50s and
she's still threatening her 23 year old
24 year old he's that's scary she know
who i am
does she know what i can do what mm-hmm
jesus christ
real long island my parents were like
you have to apologize i said what the
[ __ ] am i apologizing for it doesn't
matter
they're like you just have to that's it
you got to get deb happy again man yup
holy [ __ ] rihanna's coming over for a
sit down
that's too funny hmm parents never leave
you anywhere as a kid
yeah in uh my sister's dance recital
they left me in the car
they just kept walking i was in the like
car seat they just left me in there
ballpark how long whole recital no not
the whole they turned around within like
five minutes but it was
i was like where the hell did that baby
go you know actually
in in high school i remember i had like
a
not a hammock but like a swing in my
backyard and i was going through a time
and i
took my ipad and i went out onto that
swing and i started
just binge watching entourage like i
just was like i'm just going to watch
this show
and i was watching it for like a weekend
straight like i just didn't get up from
from this swing my parents locked all
the doors in the house
and like heard them yelling on the
inside
and then my sister opened up the door
and they were like there she is
and they had just never looked outside
to see if i was there
my dad apparently was yelling that i
snuck out they didn't i didn't get a
text from them or anything they just
jumped to conclusions didn't look
outside no text nothing they were like
she snuck out they locked all the doors
i was just in the backyard
jesus christ broncos yeah i love it i
got a short fuse over there
oh there is they're [ __ ] nuts hot
heads
i used to be a major like major hothead
like
angry yeah i mean major but now i'm much
better but like i mean
not i literally threw a chair across my
backyard the other day nice
you guys so you guys would have good
proper screaming matches
multiple times a week yeah one time i
actually we
were sitting at dinner and i remember we
were eating penny
vodka which is my favorite dish and me
and my sister got into a fight
and i just went like this like dead
armed her and then i just went back to
eating my food and my
sister screamed her head off her and my
mom started like physically fighting
with each other like
had to be held back aunt deb was there
actually
awesome and i just sat there and
continued eating my food and they tell
this story to this day because they were
like that is one of the most psycho
things you've ever done is just hit
someone and then just continue eating
oh that's [ __ ] good i mean long
island italian you're yeah you're
you're gonna have some issues for sure
those are the things though as i get
older like you know like sometimes
you're like not wake up in the middle of
the night but you look back and you're
like oh my god i could have hurt him
like i look like he fights me and my
brother got it yeah like you know i
remember one time i threw a lighter at
him
like [ __ ] fired at him and it hit him
right here
and like if i would have hit him like
two inches up it would have blinded him
or something
[Laughter]
all right let's see do you know what
kind of cologne your dad wears
i know what it looks like what's it look
like
it's like a body no bod is it green
no it's like blue and um
is he wearing a striped shirt the guy
yes it's stripes
that doesn't sound accurate google it
jean-paul gaultier lemail i think it's
called
yeah he's [ __ ] dead on yeah can i see
it can i make sure can i double check
uh i got it yeah um yes yeah that's it
that's it
yeah yeah that's trash
yeah i mean it's 73 bucks it blooming
and you know we used to go to um
how old is your dad my dad is 53 maybe
so he's nine years older than me
yeah that's great you're rocking the
same stuff that's how i know oh you're
wearing it
no but i usually did when i was younger
really yeah
that was a game changer right there
that's not you're closer to her dad
way closer to her hundred percent you're
22 years older than her
22 years old my parents are like young
parents so yeah they're young parents
yeah i would be a young parent if you
were a parent
yeah if anybody would [ __ ] you now you
would just be an old parent
oh man sorry i'm dreading that now
you're not even gonna be like a young
spry no just no let's say a conservative
an old fat dad my new sitcom old fat dad
welcome back to old fat dad uh i think
about that
so my brother was a little older when he
had kids but he's kind of evened it out
now i'd be i'll be like 50 bringing kids
to like soccer practice that's a tough
thing that's if you started now yeah
i started now which you're not no so we
need to add like five years to that so
you'll be like
50 bringing them into the world i think
what i'll have to do i should have
i'll adopt like 16 year olds that'll be
my move i get you for two years
[Laughter]
uh any male members in your family have
a ponytail
uncle cousins no no okay no do any
members of your extended family
dj at brunch are there any brunch djs or
your family
there's no brunch djs but is there a
couple djs
there i'll say this there have been
two male djs that were not
in my ex like like a boyfriend
and like a husband okay yes not
my family they are married into the
family but now divorced
nice dj using the last hour yeah i gotta
get the dj out of the family yeah
i remember i showed up to my eighth
grade dance and one of them was the dj
tough man it was it was [ __ ] tough
it was my cousin's boyfriend it was
tough
randy it's actually dj excellent
okay
[Laughter]
shut up damn
when was the last time you had lobster
never with my family really probably on
my own time
probably like lobster uh lobster ravioli
yeah lobster rabbit lobster mac and
cheese is real it's real big with the
trash circle yeah
like i when i see that on the menu oh
yeah it's got a little truffle oil and
some
i don't know actually i'll tell you the
last time i had lobster
was with fran's family brand my co-host
okay yeah yeah her family i had lobster
at their house
at their house they are the quite the
opposite of trash
so much in the other direction yeah we
have you know lobsters at home probably
a saturday oh yeah
no we were at their house in florida for
new year's eve and they were making
lobsters
oh yeah that's glass it's pretty classy
yep
um quail eggs never
never okay how do you feel about the
pizza burger
no hawaiian pizza
hated growing up never tried it growing
up i just i just would be like
pineapple doesn't belong on pizza
because i just heard that sure
love it though yeah love it tastes so
[ __ ] good
i really do what would you consider to
be your favorite snack
my favorite snack
i would imagine so there's a there's a
lot of avenues with this because
sure when i have something salty i need
something sweet and then i
when i have something sweet i need
something salty after so interesting
i like salt and vinegar chips nice and i
like reese's
okay so salt and vinegar chips and
reese's peanut butter cups together
like i'll have the salmon in your chips
and then i'll have the reese's and i'll
go back to the sauvignon chips
let's get garbage yeah and i like
i like ice cream i really like ice cream
yeah so i don't know that's such a like
around that i think that would be my my
go-to like if i just want a snack
okay i like it uh growing up did your
family drink tang
what is tang okay yeah she'd be too
young for that i think oh really family
would be too young for that
it was into the 90s though i thought
okay powder what was the what was the
what was the preferred beverage at the
house not
soda but like if your mom would make
juice or something like tea or something
iced tea
it would be ice cream powdered ice
powder rice t-shirt without container oh
yeah
yeah would she leave the spoon in there
no
okay the wooden spoon yeah it's trash
but it makes it so good it's
so good before you pour it it was always
the most garbage households
always had the best iced tea i don't
know why and you know
the fights that would be caused when the
iced tea was put back into the fridge
and it wasn't filled back up my dad
would be so
livid at my mom yeah unbelievable in
other words you picked up
if it was like a colored thing and you
couldn't see in it and you picked it up
it was like empty
and you're like losing these goddamn
kids
any injuries sustained as a kid
this is a weird story but
when i was younger i was three years old
my sister obviously older than i was
we were playing house and i was the mom
and she was the kid
and i was going to work and she didn't
want me to go to work
so she pulled a complicated storyline
jesus christ
who wrote that we were late on the bills
she pulled my arm so hard she pulled it
out of its socket
so my dad rushed me to the hospital and
they said to him you know you really
shouldn't be swinging your daughter
around and my dad was like i wasn't
swinging her around
they were playing house she was going to
work
and they were late on the mortgage
payment you understand they didn't
believe him for a second they literally
thought that my dad like
swung me around and like pulled my arm
out of its socket i remember that
happened to kids the
the the collarbone and like or like an
arm dislocation
as a kid i had a disease growing up
called hsp
very rare disease if you look it up no
it's not like
here's the thing it was very hard for
them to diagnose
apparently this is just hearsay because
i don't really
i remember very little details about
this like i remember not being able to
walk like
all these little things and we have home
videos of me with like i had just
bruises
all over my body from top to bottom like
couldn't walk so they have like home
videos of this
and they didn't know what it was they
thought it was leukemia so my parents
like thought that i was like gonna die
as a little kid i would have night
terrors my my siblings talk about all
the time they're like you were
terrifying to be around
yeah night terrorism i had night tires i
would scream my head off in the middle
of the night
i had this disease it was crazy in the
garage down the basement apartment at
least
it was nuts but they couldn't so it it's
not supposed to last as long as it did
but the doctors couldn't figure out what
the [ __ ] i had so it just went on for
like a year
at the hospital like every week jesus
god damn dude the other name for hsp is
spring fever
which sounds like a party you would go
to in college yeah yeah
or something like like you get on the
oregon trail or something like that
yeah ray got the spring fever you're
gonna have to leave her behind
oh damn hmm uh i have a question
now that you have the car you'll be
putting gas in it i assume
yeah what will you be putting in it
regular they told me premium
did they yeah you got a premium only car
i know i didn't think too far into that
when he was like oh it's premium gas i
was like
okay i already signed the leases yeah
just like you're like there's nothing i
can do about that
what's the series on the on the um it's
an a-class
kippy is that checkout is that a220 i
have a [ __ ] key
i don't know it's not it's like one of
the most basic
mercedes you can get but it's [ __ ]
sick i will say like the inside lights
up led lights at night
so purple or like i could put
there's 64 color options just will there
be any aftermarket effects being put
into this car
no did you get the windows tinted no but
every one of my families told me to do
it yeah
of course they gotta tint the windows no
they're like you gotta get the back ones
tinted i'm like i don't i know
why why what am i trying to hide i don't
want them tinted sure
that's too funny uh hmm how old
how old were you when you got your
passport so i got it when i was
i think i was young because i went to
the bahamas we talked about this i went
to the bahamas
when i was like seven or eight but i
actually don't know if you needed a
passport at that time when i went to the
bahamas i don't think you did i think
that's under a certain agent like
as long as you just had your paper but i
definitely had it before
eighth grade it's good any guitars
hanging on the wall at your house
in my brother's room he's got a few
guitars doesn't play until he gets the
chicken
doesn't play him doesn't play him that's
trash yeah
have you ever seen your parents french
kiss in front of you yes
really i have that's something that gets
burned into your brain
is a quick answer yes unfortunately they
actually did it the other day as a joke
because because they hate when we do it
they hate when like we
me and my sister freak out obviously
right here i don't know so
my dad will just like grab my mom and
you know give her a smooch
yeah that and i remember i was gonna ask
if you've ever seen either one of your
parents get thrown in a pool
that [ __ ] you up as a kid too no but
that the visual of that
makes me uncomfortable yeah i lose all
respect for a parent
well no somebody threw my mom into the
pool at a pool party and i
i was like [ __ ] seven years old and i
ran up and just started [ __ ] punching
him in the balls
really yeah he's [ __ ] throwing my mom
in the pool [ __ ] lunatic relax
[Laughter]
jesus christ i don't like it unless it
was in the middle of a winter i mean
that's not how that's all
i hate when people throw people into
pools you don't know what's in their
[ __ ] pockets
if you throw someone in to the pool
you're an [ __ ] yeah now
but back in the day when i was it was
pretty cell phone or like not
everybody had one right yeah she was my
only ride home
how'd she get out how how did she look
how's she looking a wet t-shirt
patty popping out it's a tough look uh
when was the last time you had bagel
bites
oh very recently probably like really
last are they in the house
that's right you're at home now yeah oh
what's mom
how's your mom do at the grocery store
what kind of snacks are we talking
i'll tell you this she's slacking
because really we
at growing growing up rosario they get
to a point they start losing it and
yes 100 her cooking's been off the
grocery shopping's been off
it's it's not what you know you just
said that publicly right oh i know we
tell her every day at the house
my dad we're both getting shot yeah my
dad's reminding her no my mom is an
absolute [ __ ] saint angel like
the best per nicest person on earth i
don't know how she deals with any of us
it's insane
we just throw shots at her all day and
she just takes them she's like trying
to cook yeah no well she just has really
been slacking she doesn't put as much
love and effort into it as she used to
it happens as they get older we talk
about it a lot on the show
we had the best snacks growing up like
we had fruit roll-ups we had
gushers we had ice chips ahoy we had
oreos for a while we weren't allowed to
have oreos
because my mom heard that oreo stayed in
your stomach for seven years i don't
know where she heard that we weren't
allowed to have orioles she heard that
at the hair salon
that's some long i don't know where that
came from an oreo tree will grow in your
stomach
every cereal you can imagine we have the
bagel bites
pizza yeah wow yeah we said they were
[ __ ] shotgun and coke zeros or
cokes i mean well cold cuts always cold
cuts yeah
wait did you say elio's pizza helios
yeah dress
that's my favorite frozen it's the best
it's so i mean it's not good but
it's good for the frozen pizza oh my god
yeah would you guys do dominoes or pizza
when you were a kid
no i mean like when i was drunk yeah
dominoes
but like as a family no as a family your
parents got pizza when they got it from
like gizeppes or something
yeah sounds like he knows his way around
the pie yeah
shout out to umberto for real big shout
out to umbertos they have
the best sicilian pies
that's gonna be our next patreon goal
going to albertos and getting them i
like that you mentioned sicilian
sicilian that's pretty classy i'm
starting to become more of a sicilian
fan if i have my choice i'm going to go
for a sicilian
that's usually a better slice the
thicker yeah it's not bad man that's
like that and they
i mean i think i have all the
information i need i do have two do you
have any other ones and i got two from
patreon to do
anybody any referees or umpires in your
family local
no but i mean my dad coached like the
baseball game
growing up but did he like not umpire
though was
one of you guys on the team that he
coached my brother was okay fair enough
yes
if your dad's just coaching no kids on
the team
because i remember that one time i had a
little league coach i was like which
one's your son he's like my son doesn't
play
i'm like yeah i don't even have a cat
call the commissioner i want to trade
i'm not playing for this [ __ ] creep
this kid doesn't play what are you doing
here saturday afternoon go spend time
with your family
i know what he's doing there yeah he's
scouting the talent
checking me out in my short shorts at
right field yeah
ah it's good stuff um
oh i have one uh anyone in your family
interviewed on the local news
ever no okay but we
one of the auditions i did as a kid was
for um
like an optimum tv commercial and they
were like they're like can you bring one
of the members in for you from your
family and my dad came into the audition
with me it was like the best day of his
life
we didn't get it but it was like the
best day ever
he's he's looking in the mirror it's my
big day this is my big shot
it was he was so nervous it was
hilarious because uh
so many years of him [ __ ] i'd go into
the audition afterwards that i have to
recite every single thing that happened
in that audition what did they say to
you oh is that really all they said and
then i'd have to recount it 500 times
more
it's crazy so when he got to go in there
i was like so what did they say to you
how'd it go just like really nailed it
to him yeah yeah
um the only question i have i mean my
decisions made up obviously
i mean i was kind of i mean it was i
gotta be honest i was prejudiced before
we started
if we're being honest i like
when i first started working at barstool
and everyone
found out i was like not found out they
knew i was from long island whatever
everyone would call
me long island trash all the time and it
really would get to me like i'd be like
am i gonna be like i'm not i'm not long
island trash
lately i've just been like i am lost my
own trash
like for the past year of my life i've
been like you know what i've
i really [ __ ] am like that's it and
i'm proud of it we're the same way we're
like we almost decided to
celebrate it yeah celebrate i think
being trashy is better
it's so much more fun it's so much more
fun it's great
salt to the earth people yes right there
uh with that being said i just have one
final question
uh who is your mother's favorite artist
prince
god damn right out of the textbook huh
yeah
prince really yeah that's perfect
yeah i uh long island girl like yeah
like
a nice prince loves prince gloves that's
so great
i have two from the patreon so when you
join the patreon we'll answer your
garbage question on the
air this one is uh
have you ever puked in a bar not in the
bathroom
yes yeah recently not recently okay
but just like like under the bar like
very secretly
yeah that's really yeah under the bar
under the bar very
entire shoe or something well can i
actually say that
it maybe it was a little more recent
than i'd like to admit in the past
couple of years this
couple came up to me and they were like
rio we'd love to buy you a shot we'd
love to get you a tequila shot
i was like okay i don't really love
taking shots but i'll do it now i like
it but
a few years ago i was like no did it
literally like puked up right under the
table and i was like i told you guys
it was very important yeah it was very
embarrassing but one of those things i
had to own because i was like i told you
guys
you're not going to go over well yeah
and then this one's from colin have you
or a family member snuck your own
alcohol on a plane so you don't have to
buy it from the flight attendant
no no yeah okay that's the classy answer
you'll have a cocktail on the plane
though
yes there you go i have to have beers
before i fly
i like a little like white wine on the
plane
pretty close
i'll smoke before and then take the edge
off a little while
take a little edible maybe like half of
xanax
it's like you're going to cleveland
relax [ __ ] it's an hour and 10
minutes
let's see that started out so classy
yeah what do you like in a plan like a
little white wine
after a sarah quilt yeah if you got any
blow
a little blow's not my thing but
yeah you're not supposed to be that true
yeah yeah you're really getting dealt to
come yeah
my god ria what a nice what a fantastic
episode thank you much for sitting in
with us um anything you want the folks
out there to know
you got coming up etc etc just follow
chicks in the office everywhere
instagram twitter although not enough
characters on twitter so it's chicks in
the off i'm barcelona on twitter
and then maria chiffo on instagram
that's ciufo i feel like i have to spell
that out because nobody would be able to
find that
yeah there you go chiffo i love it yes
kippy what do you got for him guys as
always
uh cameron comedy on all social media
follow the ru garbage page on twitter
and
ig it's just that are you garbage and
then you know itunes youtube and patreon
you can come out to a live show we're
gonna be all over the [ __ ] country
gonna be all over the place come and see
us gang
we love you and we'll see you next week
peace